hello and welcome back media hysteria
reaching a new level of absurdity after
news broke of a possible Trump
indictment CNN assembling an entire
panel of hard-hitting journalists to
dissect every breaking detail including
what the special counsel
ordered for lunch watch
turns out even Jack Smith can't resist a
five dollar footlong what is important
is the imagery here they clearly wanted
us to see him uh and and that image to
be very different from what we saw in
the president former president's post
with which is that he's a a deranged
individual Jack Smith is tight-lipped he
was spotted today by CNN going to Subway
for lunch picking up a sandwich leaving
and not saying a word Jack Smith going
to Subway today is a message to Donald
Trump Donald Trump tries to intimidate
people he tries to bully people he tries
to scare you away that was Jack Smith
with no words and a simple five dollar
Sub in his hand saying I'm here I'm not
going to yeah the imagery was uh was
intentional in Spoke volumes God I'm
here I'm not going anywhere tough stuff
all right is the message in the mail
correspondence serving up more tasty
details on Smith's sandwich
he stood in line just like everybody
else and I couldn't tell whether it was
a foot long or is it a uh or was it a
six-inch sub uh but look I mean the the
we now are on on watch for when this uh
potential indictment is coming
uh we are on foot long watch Judge you
know I'm I'm of the mind that this was
not a six inch I think he went all the
way
yeah well then he would have to pay ten
dollars right it's five dollars for a
six inch so if he is of the people he
bought the six inch but here's the thing
the fact that they have to go to that
level to interpret this as a message to
Donald Trump they do they suffer from
Trump derangement syndrome it was like
the hearings today you have these
whistleblowers Hunter Biden Joe Biden
taxes but it's all about Donald Trump I
mean they can't stop with the Donald
Trump stuff and the fact that they spent
time interpreting a guy going to launch
is if you know all of us don't go to
lunch every day if we're working I mean
give me a break I have nothing to say
it's so stupid it's not worth commenting
on now Jessica you and I are both fans
of casual dining and you know everybody
you and I both will die on that Hill
yeah no shame in that game
I'm I'm just wondering like there could
be some very serious Fallout from this
investigation so what am I missing why
why the sandwich
for Jack Smith or conversation
we're all familiar that moment where
people say okay you're on air for the
next 20 minutes and we have no news so
they had but they had gone over a lot of
stuff because it's pretty serious right
so there are three Federal statutes that
he's being accused of violating we know
that the grand jury Witnesses say this
investigation is about what happened
before the election I saw this crazy
clip of Peter Navarro who worked in the
Trump Administration talking about and
he wrote about this in his book too
about how Steve Bannon orchestrated all
of this ahead of time and Mike Pence was
the quarterback and he was a Green Bay
Packer so I guess maybe that's where
he's from I'm not sure just laying out
the whole plot so yes I could have used
more of that and less sandwich but I
have no Subway shade I I like subway
um
Jesse
let's say there is an indictment let's
say that that this letter that was
delivered to the president uh is very
serious does it hurt or help him at this
point given uh the Alvin Bragg
indictment well I think it helps him in
the primary but it could cost him in the
general it's a lot and he's going to
have to go to three different trials
four by the time uh Georgia comes okay
thank you for that four different trials
while he's running for president it's a
lot it's a lot and he's going to have to
win and then pocket pardon himself
used to be the special counselor in the
90s he couldn't leave his house without
getting mobbed they had him staked out
wherever he went and they'd get right up
in his face and they and they and they'd
scream at him and they'd call them names
and they'd say it was a bad guy he was
hurting the country
they're treating this guy like Kim
Kardashian like they're TMZ and they're
like oh he stood in line like everybody
else they're trying to make him a
celebrity and that's what they do they
demonize the president and they lionize
the prosecutor they did it with Alvin
Bragg remember Cuomo they made him a
hero Cassidy the woman who testified
that he was you know Reaching Across
Secret Service agents from the back of
the car they do this with people they
did it with Mueller Weissman all these
guys have book deals they're all heroes
they never have to buy another drink in
their life but that's how the media is
framing it and it's grossly unfair
because the guy is just a schlep Jack
Smith Smith oh his record is horrible
terrible prosecutor yeah it's really
awful I mean the guitar track alone was
so lackluster I don't know you know I'm
thinking about Subway you got Jared
Fogle you got Megan rapino and a got
this guy
what message are they expecting that
that trip to send that he can't afford
Applebee's I don't get this it's like oh
they certainly John King saying he's not
intimidated from eating a sandwich this
makes no sense it's good to see CNN
returning to the hard news that made
them so reputable 30 years ago seven
paneled segment on a guy getting a
sandwich because the guys are so focused
on Trump what's next a live town hall on
Stormy Daniels getting a facial I don't
know but maybe she's outlived her
utility so they don't need her anymore
you're right about Trump's derangement
but the one part about that is that they
assume we all have it and if you don't
have it there's something wrong with you
we're also supposed to see the same
message that the they they see or were
The Crazy Ones they remind me of the
people who used to see religious icons
in like trees and food like ah there's a
likeness of Jesus in my toast or there's
Mary on my on in the tree bark they see
Trump in everything and I always say
this when you make fun of this you got
to look at yourself and make sure you're
not doing the same thing with your uh
your opposition you can't have Biden
derangement syndrome there are people
that had Obama derangement syndrome who
saw him as some out evil Outsider and
still do so you gotta I still suffer
from it I know you do I know you do and
I have some pills for you good thank you
you're welcome yeah I'll take seven yes
Jesse showed me his real birth
certificate and I should say wow needed
an atlas
thank you
all right now he's American I wanna
Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now